somehow Star Wars
returned and Star Trek
returned and Mad Max returned and
Halloween returned and again uh and
again they're just all coming
[Music]
back hey folks anybody remember when
franchises used to be allowed to
die I do or at least I think I do I'm
starting to wonder if that was a
fanciful fever dream of
Youth I suppose in a way it actually
kind of
was before I start going off on this
entire thing because I'm probably
goingon to go off a little
bit I think it would behoove me to be
clear that franchises particularly in
entertainment in film in television
video games whatever are not
new they have existed for ages one of my
favorite old film series is the Thin Man
there was the first one that was
actually based off a book and then they
made five more they're pretty good only
the sixth one is not especially good the
rest are at least decent if not great
but like franchises aren't a new thing
the quintessential franchise for a long
time was James Bond at least when it
came to film and franchising for
entertainment taking something
continuing it on past what one might
think would be the normal lifespan of
the story that was being told or
branching it off into spin-offs and uh
additional stuff soft reboots uh late
continuations Etc it does it just feels
like it's picking up pace a lot and more
to the point it feels like nothing ends
anymore now that actually is also not a
new problem but it used to be far more
contained the number of things that felt
like they never ended used to be a
pretty small number of very specific
things daytime soap operas felt like
they never ended long running superhero
comic books felt like they never ended
well heck not even just superhero Archie
feels like it never ends of course so
again this overall thing that I'm going
to be talking about this notion that
franchises are just allowed to finish to
be done that is something that is
increasing but I don't want to pretend
like it's a holy new thing but it has
gotten worse there were a couple things
that made me want to talk about this and
understand uh to sort of tip my hand to
where I'm going ultimately what I'm
going to be talking about more than
anything is the mentality of the
executive class of the companies that
own most of the entertainment that we
consume so that's what I'm got to be
kind of focusing on or at least building
up to but before we get there there are
a couple of things that made me go oh
really really first of all back in
September there was word that there is
uh being shopped around the possibility
of more Halloween films now this is
following the wake of the film Halloween
ends which is the end of a Trilogy from
a God I don't even know what to call
them reboot quill a continuation of the
original film that ignored all previous
sequels which Halloween had already kind
of done once before with a movie called
Halloween H2O which ignored everything
after the first two films but then there
was the Halloween that ignored
everything after the first film and
that's not even counting the actual
full-on reboot that got two films and
they're talking about still continuing
this why how is there blood left in this
Stone because it's an own property
that's why uh another thing I saw the
trailer for the next uh Planet of the
Apes movie movie and I remember thinking
the last Planet of the Apes movie was
not that long ago and like it finished
the story it finished Caesar's story it
finished the story that it was telling
but here we are we're going to do more I
mean I again there is kind of precedent
for that the original Planet of the Apes
series was five films long and not only
the first one is good fourth one is
actually quite good in my estimation but
you know there's some precedent for that
but the third one did finish up its
story in terms of the more recent
films but they're going to do
more and then David
zazo over at Warner
Brothers I forget when he said this it
might not have been this recent but it
has been stuck in my head ever since he
said it we're going to read this whole
quote one of the real strengths of
Warner Brothers as we talk about the
great IP that Warner Brothers owns but
for us it's the challenge is that our
content our great IP Harry Potter DC
Lord of the Rings that content has been
underused we haven't done anything with
Harry Potter for more than a decade we
haven't done anything with Lord of the
Rings we think there's a lot of
shareholder value in attaching a 10-year
DC a real plan around DC bringing Harry
Potter back to HBO for 10 consecutive
years doing multiple movies a Lord of
the Rings when you put those franchises
in it's the best performing studio in
the world we need to deploy our best
Capital we need to do it with the best
creative people in the world where do we
even start with this how about the fact
that the idea of creative people being
involved only gets a mention at the very
end because right now with the way that
people like David's zasso or like Bob
Iger over at Disney or like any of these
massive entertainment conglomerations
with the way that they
operate they only see creative people
you know the people who actually write
direct act Etc they only have input on a
project that the executives have already
decided that's going to happen the place
for creatives is polishing up and
presenting the most digestible version
of the thing that the executives have
already decided is going to make all the
money so it's very telling that they are
brought up literally at the very end and
it's kind of sad specifically that it's
Warner Brothers because you know once
upon a time about a decade ago granted
Once Upon a Time Warner Brothers used to
be known as a place that would get its
hands on really talented directors and
back them on stuff that they cared about
doing whether that was a major thing
that the studio wanted or not now
granted sometimes those directors would
have to kind of work to earn that
Goodwill but you look at people like
Christopher Nolan or heck even Zack
Snyder they both worked a lot with
Warner Brothers and they got to do
various passion projects and there were
many others before them but that's just
not what Warner Brothers is anymore
honestly that's not what Warner Brothers
has been for a while this the mask is
off now but that's you know that's the
first thing creatives barely a mention
at the back end and we'll try and move
past the fact that he says they haven't
done anything with Harry Potter in 10
years when it hasn't even been 10 years
since the first fantastic Beast movie
came out and you haven't done anything
in Harry Potter for 10 years you did
three movies in a series that you had
originally plann to do five movies in
but then you had to stop because nobody
wanted it and multiple video games that
have been frustratingly successful you
haven't done anything what he means is
nothing has had the official words Harry
Potter on it because from his from his
perspective the Wizarding World stuff oh
that's all spin-off stuff we're not
making use of the IP the intellectual
property people know I don't know if he
actually talks like this but in my mind
he does this is just the kind of guy he
is the intellectual property that people
know the words Harry Potter we haven't
said Harry Potter for
years and the fact that he said he wants
to do Harry Potter on HBO for a decade
when I was pretty sure and maybe I'm
misremembering this that the
announcement for a Harry Potter TV show
The the idea was to do a season per book
and yet he appears to have just tipped
his hand that they're going to milk it
for way more than that if they think
they can DC I'm almost willing to give a
pass to because again it's based off a
form of media that does kind of go on
forever without an ending I.E superhero
comic book so like I'm almost willing to
let him have that one but then there's
Lord of the Rings I keep forgetting
there's going to be a Lord of the Rings
movie this year it's at least schedule
for this year we'll see if it comes out
this year if it hits next year I keep
forgetting about that you know why cuz
the story's done three films were made
the definitive visual Trilogy Of The
Lord of the Rings and then you milked
The Hobbit which is shorter than any one
of the books that you made a whole movie
Out of with Lord of the Rings you took a
book that was shorter than any one of
those and made three movies out of it
that were increasingly
bad like the story's
done but they're still going to make
more because the IP is being
underutilized let's talk about the
executive mentality and words like
underutilize because that is the thing
that you need to realize about the
perspective of these Executives because
first of all these executives are not
creative people and I'm not saying that
to knock them like literally the
creatives are shut out of the executive
level by and large
by design that is the case you may
notice if you pay attention a lot of
Executives not just in entertainment and
Hollywood but a lot of Executives they
tend to move not only from Studio to
Studio but sometimes industry to
Industry they'll go from a business that
does one thing to a completely different
business and still be at the top even
though it's a business they have never
run before but it's just presumed that
because they know how to run a business
those Notions those thought those
techniques they apply to everything
which means you treat everything the
same and you treat it as numbers and
when the thing that you made that made
you the most money got the most prestige
the most attention you're not currently
making that's money left on the table
but but we exhausted The Source material
it doesn't matter but we finished the
story we were telling doesn't matter you
could be making more you you could be
doing more I'll give you another example
for something that I enjoyed initially
when it came back but then I I I'm
already losing interest Ghostbusters the
original Ghostbusters is possibly still
my favorite movie of all time it's
definitely in the top five I don't like
Ghostbusters 2 I think that was one of
my first disappointments growing up as a
kid going to the
theater uh the reboot I didn't
especially like not because they were
women just cuz it it was okay it's just
what it was I actually quite enjoyed
Ghostbusters afterlife that was heavily
Nostalgia I absolutely admit to that I'm
not excited for the sequel
especially because the late arriving
followup which is its own Trend that
very much fits into all this but the
late arriving follow up to
Ghostbusters that was successful great
now let's start cranking out more
sequels no but the the appeal to that
was it had been a long time since that
version of Ghostbusters have been
touched but this is something Executives
don't ever take into their calculations
they don't think of the fact that
absence actually increases the impact of
a thing the way that they think is that
if You released a sequel
you know a sequel to something that has
been dormant for a while and it's a
hit from their perspective all the years
in which you weren't making sequels you
could have been making that money and
you didn't you blew it so let's get
going now as sequels as fast as we can
do them spin-offs everything you can do
because we don't want to be leaving the
money on the table like we did before
because we weren't utilizing the
IP the the idea that part of the love
part of the excitement was that it went
away for a
bit does not occur to these people I
mean it it literally doesn't because
another factor in this this is what
leads to films like that awful Fantastic
Four the one that everyone calls fan for
stick films like that get made in order
to hold on to the film rights not
because they think they actually have a
good movie to make not because they
actually think that this one will be
successful but because if they let the
rights lapse and go to somebody else and
that other Studio make something
successful they have to answer for the
fact that they let whatever the profit
on that was go to somebody
else they don't care if it's
artistically valid they care if they can
point to something and go this has made
us money before so we're going to keep
doing it and look realistically holding
on to existing IPS franchises that
people know that is a form of risk
avoidance just
statistically a sequel to something that
people already know is statistically
more likely to earn its money back than
something that they have never heard
of that that is the reality but that's
the thing statistics run this at this
point I've noted before that for all the
Panic that we have about AI taking over
the creative fields the ones who should
really be worried are the executives
because they think very much the way
algorithms and AI think you feed them
the data of what has been successful
before and their answer is awesome do it
again do more of it more more that name
that brand that franchise it was
successful do it more that's what an AI
would do they should actually be very
concerned about their jobs of being
taken over by AI not that I think that
would actually be a good thing but
honestly in most most cases I don't
think AI would run Studios much worse in
some of these cases and the thing is I
mentioned franchises have been a thing
for a while but honestly if we go far
enough back especially with movies the
real
franchises they used to be the actors
you'd go to a Fred a stair movie an
Errol Flynn movie and that held true you
know even into later years with your
Arnold Schwarzenegger movies your Tom
Cruz movies and some of these actors are
even still around but to take Tom Cruz
you don't really go to see a Tom Cruz
movie anymore you go to see Mission
Impossible specifically because that's
the Tom Cruz vehicle and there was even
a time say 70s into the 80s where
directors could be big names and
sometimes a handful of them still are
but it used to be a big deal to go see a
Spielberg movie a scors sey movie Hell a
West Craven
movie but now these days most upand
cominging directors their big hope is to
have a hit indie film and then get moved
on to and then get shifted to be the
creative person on the big established
IP the director of the next Marvel movie
even though they won't be allowed to
direct a lot of it the director of the
next DC movie that they don't get to
pick what it's going to be they just
have to do what's already been planned
out and hope they can put as much spin
on it as they can of their own stuff and
this is very much what executives want
they want the brand to be the thing I'm
sure that many of them are irritated
that there are still some franchises
that they believe could be bankable that
are too tied to specific people be they
writers directors or more or more likely
actors that it's probably not viable to
try and continue it without those people
involved that they can't just keep the
thing going because did you know that
there have been years like over a decade
at this point attempts to do a DieHard
year one movie do a young John mlan
because Bruce Will is well at this point
he's fully retired from
acting but you know they want to use the
Diehard
name but they
can't they've been trying but it hasn't
worked it's too tied to the one guy is
Indiana Jones too tied to Harrison Ford
to ever be picked up or continued I
would argue probably what honestly
entertainment entities want is they want
what the video game world has which is
that yeah there's franchises in terms of
game series but when you promote yo this
is coming from H it's not the developers
it's not the creative director it's the
studio the studio which might have a
completely different staff from the last
time they made a game in that series but
they make the studio the brand the
latest game from Ubisoft the latest game
from blizzard the latest game from
Nintendo who are the people who actually
made it sh Nintendo made it the studio
made
it that is what movie and TV uh
companies want more than anything else
they want to be able to say well it's
from our studio that's enough for you to
want it right they don't have that but
they want it and the closest that they
can get to it is to push these Brands
push these franchises as hard as they
possibly can you can tell they don't
have anything else to do they have no
other ideas the fact that the only three
that David zoff could think to name off
Lord of the Rings DC and Harry Potter
that is two-thirds of the same lineup
that a Warner Brothers God over a decade
ago said we're going to be the pillars
of their entire movie bases going
forward and that led to just a mess back
then they didn't mention Lord of the
Rings instead they mentioned Lego which
they don't anymore cuz they had to let
it go but these things will never be
allowed to reach a natural conclusion
and this is why when people ask me
things like do you think the MCU is is
ending I don't think the MCU will ever
end it'll scale down I think it's peaked
it'll scale down it'll dial back I don't
think it'll ever go away fully
because there's too many Executives
going okay but we used to be able to
release multiple of these a year and
people were into them so we can't just
let the whole thing go dormant let's see
if we can relight this fire they won't
let it
die the most that ever happens is
something goes dormant for a little bit
usually because it's just been stalled
out and pre-production for too long like
say that di hard prequel idea was but by
and large
this stuff isn't allowed to die anymore
when they bring something back that has
been asleep they don't think oh we get
to we get to do more with this franchise
they they think ah we could have been
doing more this whole time and we
weren't
it's all money left on the table if
you're not actively milking now does
that mean every franchise will be
revived every franchise will continue
forever no there are things out there
that are left to die but there're
usually things that were always
Niche I suppose I should have been more
specific Blockbuster franchises will
never be allowed to Die the smaller
things the more Niche things the things
that have uh weird complicated copyright
issues uh and ownership issues around
them like say Friday the 13th yeah those
will go dormant for long periods and be
effective ly dead for a while but if
there's even a
chance and somebody can get a hold of it
who can think to do something with
it they'll try because the money is in
the known
properties and that's been that way for
a
while you know it used to be that
sequels were always expected to make
less than the previous
entry that used to be the model there
were exceptions along the way Terminator
2 made more than Terminator 1 though
that's also weird because there was a
big gap of time in between those two but
I think that started turning around with
superhero
movies Spider-Man makes a ton of money
Spider-Man 2 made even more X-Men makes
a bunch of money X-Men 2 makes even more
iron man makes a bunch of money Iron Man
2 makes a bunch of money uh Thor Captain
America Avengers makes all the
money that seems to be where the sequels
actually make as much if not more
started to overtake and become the
expectation if not the
norm because one of the
benefits of accepting the idea that each
sequel makes a little bit less money
than the one before is that it accepts
the notion that things have a natural
life cycle eventually those diminishing
returns will diminish so much that like
we'll just stop it's not worth it
anymore but if that's not the
conventional wisdom anymore and if the
numbers say sequels can make more money
than their
predecessors then it means you don't
stop rolling the dice you keep going
because yeah this one made less money
than the one before but what if the next
one jumps it back up again cuz they do
they they don't always keep going down
so roll the dice
again
it's
frustrating and it's difficult to hold
on to the love of a thing when it
doesn't
stop again some properties some mediums
are better equipped for this than others
I'd say Doctor Who is pretty well
equipped because you have the nice
sectioning off of eras with each
regeneration Star Trek um thanks to how
successful the next generation was is
decently equipped for this so that a new
series can bring about their own thing
and have their uh their own sort of mini
franchise within the larger franchise
like that can weather it a bit Marvel if
they hadn't completely egged the pudding
in the last few years could have
weathered it but they may have blown it
that doesn't mean it's going to be
allowed to die but some franchises are
better built than others to sustain
through these things but others they're
just going to keep limping along it's
hard for me to have much enthusiasm for
Star Wars anymore because what even is
this what are we
doing I know that these things being
done aren't because somebody was
passionate about the story I mean you
want to go back to my childhood with
Star Wars the expanded universe now
rebranded as Star Wars Legends since
Disney bought it
they had all this stuff
these games and comic books and so many
novels I never took in any of it I just
wasn't
interested but it didn't bum me out that
they existed cuz yeah they made money
but not a ton and generally if somebody
worked on one of these things probably
because they had an idea and they were
passionate about it but
now the new Star Wars movies the new
Star Wars
shows they exist
because somebody in an Executive Suite
said hey we should have a Star Wars film
or TV show on our calendar for this for
this date and I'm not pretending that
movies and TV weren't always a business
yeah I know they
were but there used to be a lot more
push and pull
between the studio saying we want
somebody to make this because we think
it'll make us money and creatives going
I want to make this because I'm
passionate about it and it feels like so
much more is dictated by the executives
at this point and part of this is the
death of the mid-budget movie because
what used to happen is yeah you'd have
your major tent poles and maybe those
were your big franchises but you'd have
you know your 40 to70 million movies
that could allow for more freedom yeah
not as many toys for the directors who
were going in for those but you can do
what you want you can have a lot more
freedom you can do your passion project
if you can keep it on
budget these Studios they don't make mid
budget anymore because they want the
highest
returns and the statistics tell them
that the highest returns are on
franchises with $150 million plus
budgets so that is virtually all that
gets made anymore I say franchises will
never be allowed to die well all of this
collapse in on itself well will we be
looking at a situation like say in the
70s where you know after all this bloat
of massive uh and and excessively
expensive film making gives way to and
you know passionate younger people like
Spielberg and George Lucas and Francis
for Copa and the 70s and bring in a wave
of creativity that reinvigorates
everything I mean it's
possible I don't know
though the thing is the young creatives
as I said have been funneled into the
system it's hard to fight against it
when it's already appropriated
you so I don't know but it's just kind
of the state of where things are at and
it's at this state because
the executives at these companies these
companies that are far too big and own
far too
much they only want what gives them the
biggest returns because that's what
guarantees they keep the shareholders
happy and that's what guarantees their
bonuses one of the most infuriating
things to hear about in the production
of any piece of entertainment be it
movie TV or video game is to hear when
something is either put on the schedule
in the first place or rushed to meet a
deadline and the main reason for that
deadline is to ensure the bonus of a of
an
executive it
happens a
lot but on that um frustrating note I
think we'll close
out franchises are not going away
anytime soon not while these companies
are this big and run by these kinds of
people
so maybe the solution is uh can we get
somebody in there start breaking these
companies up or at the very least stop
letting them
merge stop letting them acquire each
other just
stop oh well whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living and sit here and rant at you for
a while and uh even if you can't help me
out that way like share subscribe they
all help me out don't worry too much
about it though what I really want you
to remember is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved you are
the council and I'm just running the
meetings until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned drum roll for my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Z Lula
goddess Ela Oliver be to rock the thing
that goes dink in the anime Ruth go of
the gazarian solitary pictures olrick
Bogden geek filter Linda Walters Toby
Jackson Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
fori likes the poodle Robin Powell TLO
Cy scrapbot angry caspel Dave Hall quite
bearish Rosalyn Bennett pal baraba Jole
and miror G thanks so
[Music]
much
w
a